we're featuring my interview with
science communicator extraordinaire Bill
Nye and I asked how his interest in
comedy and his background in engineering
coalesced into the identity of the
Science Guy let's check it out it's a
wonderful thing to get people to laugh
at your comedy jokes and so I started
doing stand-up or trying to do stand-up
well I can stand up clubs and stuff yeah
yeah so I would work on a drawing board
and then I would go home and take a nap
and then go to comedy clubs so you were
engineer by day comedian by night sir
yes I wrote that what I was trying to do
it's a problem the thing that always
trump is Engineering still in your head
at some yeah I miss it
while you're doing that yeah I yeah so
what's the stick engineering informed
yes that's what I say hilarious jokes
about electrocuting yourself while
trying to fix a blender Wow is that
funny and chewing marshmallows frozen in
liquid nitrogen so that steam comes out
of your nose hilarious
come on it's a payoff and I realized
that what I wanted to do you know I came
of age at a time for me as mechanical
engineer is really troubling we had the
Chevy Vega and the Ford Pinto and these
were just badly designed cars the
administration decided not to embrace
the metric system something you and I
haven't fully agreed on is my belief
there's America yeah yeah the United
States was falling behind industrially
is America so I got very concerned about
the future I'm not kidding it very
concerned and I realized working at the
Science Center in Seattle that young
people are the key to the future I mean
this is obvious but they're the key to
our industrial future they're in key to
our economic competitiveness they're the
future of civilization civilization and
so I wanted to get kids excited about
science in the same way I had been
excited about science by my teachers and
a television guy named Don Herbert mr.
wizard I remember mr. wizard so all this
came together into a unique arc of life
that's my claim that's my story
[Applause]
[Music]